ernesto ha remado en su bote un total de
50 kilómetros esto lo hizo los últimos
cinco días vamos a marcar información
importante remo 50 kilómetros en
cinco días ok cada día remo la misma
distancia cuántos kilómetros remo
ernesto cada día para que nosotros
podamos visualizar esto vamos a imaginar
lo siguiente haremos esta línea
representando los 50 kilómetros que ha
remado ernesto y 50 km
el total de esta distancia es 50 km y
tenemos la información de que esto en
los últimos 5 días lo cual implicaría
que estos 50 kilómetros son la suma de 5
pequeños bloques de lo que remo cada día
y esto esta gran línea es el total si
dice que cada día remo la misma
distancia
eso significa que haremos fragmentos de
igual tamaño de estos 50 kilómetros
vamos a pensar en 5 días haremos un
total de cinco bloques iguales uno
quito
4 y 5 ahora si se ven de la misma
distancia si nosotros buscamos saber
cuál es la distancia de un solo día
este es un día dos días tres días cuatro
días cinco días lo que haremos es
dividir 50 km
/
cinco días
el total de los kilómetros entre los
cinco días que remo la misma distancia y
tendremos como resultado que 50 entre 5
es igual a 10
es km cada día
ritmo
cada día
y listo con eso hemos terminado se dan
cuenta que estuvo muy sencillo